but I can't understand talking sex
what's the text guaranteed sex Oh sex
[Music]
let's go I'm actually getting out of
construction and start my own business
we call it trampolining world Gymnastics
and trampolining are amongst the fastest
growing sports in America
no offense brother but you need to get
laid
I'd like to introduce you to Zane what
do you like you want to get weird no I
don't want to get weird nine months ago
I was engaged to the most wonderful girl
in the world
[Music]
I lost the one thing I ever truly cared
about once the winners lead he back and
thinks that celibacy is the way to go
not always the way sorry I'm out he let
me fix this and I'll invest in
trampoline world
I need sixty thousand dollars you only
need 60 grand to start a business in
America a great country this is
[Music]
you gotta do something dramatic you're a
new man
[Music]
what are you calling it
traveling world no you're not calling it
that
[Music]
finances had a story I've ever heard
[Music]
you